[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
with their sky-high kicks and glittering
costumes the Rockettes
are in every way American icons the
dance company has been around for nearly
a century famously performing at New
York City's Radio City Music Hall and
shows like the Christmas Spectacular but
only the best of the best will ever get
the chance to dance on Radio City stage
so what does it take to earn the coveted
title of a Rockette and how do these
dancers put on one of the most
anticipated events of the holiday season
it takes a really special human being to
be a Rockette because you are one of a
line and you can't really be a soloist
and as a dancer that sometimes is a
challenge but it's what these women love
and it makes it really special to be a
member of that team by late September
frosting for the Christmas Spectacular
is complete and it's time for the
dancers to start rehearsals
[Music]
for her six hours a day six days a week
for about six weeks before we open up
the show
[Music]
choreography integrates several styles
of dance so the Rockettes must be ready
to adapt to tap jazz and ballet
[Music]
this year's show presented another
challenge learning how to dance with
drums
so the finale for the Christmas
Spectacular this year is based on the
concept of Christmas lights there will
be 100 drones and circling the stage and
revealing the Rockettes behind a drone
curtain I think it's gonna be amazing I
mean the people they've been working on
this for months
dancing isn't all that's required from
the Rockettes when it's Showtime that is
something that a lot of people don't
realize is that we show up and we do our
own hair our own makeup we have an
amazing team behind the scenes that are
choreographed alongside us to help us
with our costume changes one of our
custom changes is actually 78 seconds
and it's from our afraid of the wooden
soldiers so we have a lot of pieces the
wooden soldiers is an iconic number that
we've had in the show since 1933 so
there really is no room for error we
spend a lot of time on the soldier fall
because it has to be so precise we have
a certain amount of steps that we do in
between each move we start nice and
small and then we slowly go over the
line so that way once all 36 of us are
on stage and smooth and seamless and we
work as one strong unit in a way the
parade of the wooden soldiers is more
than a dance number it's a visual
representation of what it really takes
to be a Rockette and why that title has
held such esteem for nearly a hundred
years
so the Radio City Rockettes are the only
dance company where precision is
absolutely a priority it's what
separates us from anybody else as
dancers everything you see is detailed
out to how high your arm is where your
cheek is where your eyes are looking
every move every move you make is like
mapped out on the stage to create
perfect pattern
[Music]
so as the rock has continued to evolve
as a dance company we always hold on to
that precision and that tradition
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you